hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter four of book one of his work
on duties Cicero is going to draw out a
very important connection between nature
and reason reason being something that
human beings among all the other animals
alone enjoy a possess employ and that
turns out to make all the difference now
what he's doing here is in fact sort of
a great manifestation of what we call
early natural law theory which has to do
with the notion that there is some sort
of inclinations or or tendencies
implanted in us as well as in in the
case of many of these other animals by
virtue of being the kinds of things that
we are so the Stoics would say by nature
by nature which creates us as our
natures ie as human nature or animal
nature in other respects and we can use
reason which is another thing that that
we're endowed with by nature to think
out what the you might say consequences
or implications of these inclinations or
fundamental desires really are and ought
to be and we can use that as providing
us moral guidance so why is this coming
up in a book on duties we can actually
understand how we ought to behave as
human beings by looking at what our
nature is and you know what it is that
nature has given us so Cicero talks
first of all about other animals and we
have this just as much as they do
although it doesn't always work in quite
the same way in part because our
rationality makes us different from them
but he says that nature and dows animals
with what we can call instincts or
inclinations now of course we know that
animals particularly as we get to higher
level animals are quite a bit more
plastic in how these drives play out
than the ancients thought that they were
right but we can put that aside for the
moment and and we're also not going to
worry over much about whether you know
higher animals like elephants or apes or
cetaceans like you know whales and
dolphins or even octopi which are
incredibly intelligent or apparently
certain kinds of birds show something
like rationality we're not going to
worry too much about that we're mostly
interested in what it means for us human
beings so nature and dows animals with
certain instincts or inclinations and
the first one that he talks about is for
self-preservation and this covers quite
a bit of ground this involves you know
moving towards certain things desiring
those things that are going to conduce
to our living that are going to help
keep us alive like you know the desire
to eat the desire to drink the desire to
find shelter although that could be
about avoiding harm as well you know
other desires that we have for like
laying in the Sun well turns out that we
actually need you know those ultraviolet
rays to help us out and we could go on
and on and on we might get me a more
specific about talking about the role of
bitterness and sweetness but this one
doesn't go into that so we're not going
to worry about that at this point and it
isn't talking awful lot about this this
self-preservation at this point but
notice that it's not just for animals
it's also for for us and we are animals
then we have a another set of drives
when we reach a certain age we wish to
reproduce and all animal life does this
in one way or another sometimes their
mating rituals and methodologies may
seem rather bizarre to us like we
picture to ourselves mantises and and
spiders where the female grabs the male
who she's usually larger that and eats
him up but there maybe there's some
evolutionary advantage there the the
biologists tell us that we don't have to
worry about that point is all of them
engaged in reproduction all of them are
motivated by some form of sexual desire
and many animals at least do something
to try to
at least take care of set up the
environment for their young whether it
be you know wasps that are laying
there's their eggs within a spider who
they've paralyzed or a caterpillar two
tortoises you know burying their eggs
all the way to you know really cool
things like you know male seahorses
carrying the little babies around and
even in all scorpions with little
scorpions on top
spiders guarding their egg sac until
they they hatch and then we get to
higher and higher levels and we see you
know like different animals actually
taking care of their young and doing
more than that sometimes even going
beyond merely nurturing them and warding
off threats teaching them you know we
know that you know cats for example you
know little kittens need to see some
other cat doing certain things in order
for them to figure out how to kill their
prey instead of just playing around with
it very cool stuff right and again
Cicero is not concerned with that for
its own sake he's interested in the fact
that we human beings also do this but
then we make a kind of quantum leap by
the possession of rationality
rationality allows us to think in ways
that as far as we know animals
themselves do not do so he gives you
some some examples of this that are very
apt and very interesting he says we
comprehend the chain of consequences
perceive the causes of things we
understand relations of cause to effect
an effect to cause draw analogies
connects and associates the present in
the future we can survey the whole of
our life we can ask questions about
whether we're screwing things up or
doing things right we can take positions
on that very interesting what it affords
us the possibility to do now here's
where it gets particularly interesting
because we have this capacity
for rationality there are four main
things that Cicero is going to hit on
one of them has to do with what we might
call a social instinct he is not denying
that animals are also social both in the
sense of you know familial affection and
in the sense of you know recognizing and
dealing with their own kind and often
associating and common tasks or things
like that
but human beings have this capacity to a
much higher degree he talks about the
you know the tender affection that we
human beings have for our offspring
which you know goes to explain quite a
lot I mean if you think about it
little little kittens are born you know
with their eyes shut but they're able to
more or less get around I mean they they
have to drink milk and stuff like that
for a little while but they they get
over it and then they move around and
their little cats and development right
you know they can follow the mom cat
around if the dad can't isn't hostile to
them they can follow him around as well
and they're they're working we have
these babies that take years and years
and years before they're like not
totally helpless right so that's that's
a great example right there and then we
retain these connections with with our
children throughout our lifetime in many
cases there's all sorts of other forms
of sociality that that Cicero talks
about as well she
he says she nature she prompts men to
meet in companies to form public
assemblies to take part in them
themselves right and talks about the
fact that we actually store up not just
out of instinct but because of planning
the the resources that we're going to
need to sustain life we provide those
resources sometimes if we're not jerks
when we find other people in need so
this is something distinctively human
that's not to say that all humans do
that but many humans do and some humans
do it without having to think about it a
hell of a lot because there is a kind of
instinct there which can go
I which can be suppressed which may
sometimes be you know superseded when
these other instincts or drives or
inclinations take over another thing
that Cicero talks about truth seeking we
alone of all animals are interested in
knowing the truth not just because of
some practical value to us but because
we desire to know the truth and we see
being deceived as a bad thing
fundamentally this is this is something
that Cicero thinks is at the root of
human nature
she says the search after that he says
the search after truth and it's eager
pursuit are peculiar to human beings so
when we have leisure from the demands of
business we are eager to see to hear to
learn something new
we esteem a desire to know the secrets
or wonders of creation as indispensable
to a happy life this is part of what our
fulfillment would be the fulfillment of
our human nature another thing that he
talks about is this yearning for
independence for being freed not just
from other people but from conditions he
talks about this is a hunger enakku pity
toss and Appetit co an appetite for a
kind of rulership a kind of
self-governance you know putting putting
kippa top twist and he says that this is
also something that human beings have
because of our rational nature the last
thing that he talks about is a kind of
orderliness and the possibility of
decorum of doing things in a rational
way of arranging things in ways that
make sense to us I mean this is what's
behind
for example caring whether the grass is
cut or not because you know frankly it
doesn't doesn't matter in many respects
if your grass is cut
in your yard or it or isn't cut but
people like to see it all laid out the
same way and God forbid if you you know
just drive around randomly cutting the
grass it should be in nice neat lines
though there's a little bit of a
caricature but we human beings do engage
in a lot of these sorts of things he
says no other animal has a sense of
beauty loveliness harmony in the visible
world he says and nature and reason
extending the analogy of this from the
world of sense to the world of the mind
or the spirit find that beauty
consistency in order are far more to be
maintained in thought and in deed so not
just in how we arrange things out here
but in how we behave and how we think
and how we speak now each one of these
four is going to correspond to one of
what what we call the cardinal virtues
truth seeking to wisdom sociality to
justice orderliness to moderation or
temperance independence to courage
fortitude great-souled nasaw and so
Cicero is telling us that nature has
endowed us with the capacities for the
moral virtues for these forms of human
excellence by way of our rationality all
of this is an overlay on the rest of our
animal nature which is not bad and has
to be there in order for us to function
and when rationality is functioning
properly it actually integrates all of
this as I mentioned at the beginning
this is indeed a sort of early version
of what we will later on call natural
law theory the Stoics were some of the
the first people to really systematize
this in the West and so there is a very
strong connection between nature and
human nature and reason or rationality
for Cicero
you